You are clear that my daughter is seven
years old, she will be at the wake this afternoon,
true, yes,
and I would love to know where she will be,
but it does not occur to
you, I also have the right to fire him,
the problem is now mine,
you have already experienced evil  For a while now all the
paperwork is up to me and in fact I
want to compensate you for everything you have really
done so that she is calm, you
no longer need to go anywhere or
do anything else and we are going to fix it in
a civilized way here  In the two
that we see, as you go, I need your
money, ma'am,
it's called investigations.
Well, in any case, anything I
ask for is my fault. I'm simply
protecting my stereo, just Portland,
some loved one for themselves, but
you're not going to any funeral or
No wake understands that I don't know how
this place is, what do you want me to tell you,
Daniel? You're not going to the funeral anywhere,
please let us have the
family as it should be.
io as a mom thinks that a
whole family devastated in crashes
and I would take out a lung if necessary
for my daughter